In a phone interview, you can have all your material fanned out all around you:...
...resumes, questions, canned answers.
So, take advantage of this and keep all of your documents handy.
Next: practice.
Do a faux interview with a friend.
It's a great way to prepare.
The more comfortable you can be ahead of time,...
...the more polished and natural you'll sound during the real thing.
Finally, don't worry about brief silences.
Have you ever noticed how politicians pause before answering a question?
That's because they're mentally constructing the best response.
Do the same thing.
Don't worry about a pause here or there.
Just be sure to follow it with a thoughtful response.
I'm Cat Miller. This has been Dice TV.
And we now return you to your regular desktop.